então a gente ia começar pra você contar
um pouquinho pra vocês uma história que
aconteceu comigo mas algumas semanas
atrás uma vez meu muito próximo e como
tempo viajando com ele e ele chegou pra
mim e falou assim k é uma coisa muito
interessante o que você faz quando vocês
fariam com as reuniões que eu acho
interessante mas não teria coragem de
fazer
a olimpede foi porque é melhor pra mim e
falou de uma maneira quando fiquei muito
entusiasmado quando pode dizer que gosto
muito das pessoas
você tem uma vida interessante de
abraçar e abraçar barreiras o show ele
falou é mais engraçado de tudo é quando
você abraça a barriga das pessoas elas
acham mas ela elas acabam gostando de
você e te abraçar a renda das pessoas
porque o tempo refletindo sobre isso
realmente perceber que é iniciado com o
curioso e e ao pensar nas pessoas que
passaram no mesmo ponto e três folhas é
depois de perder a primeira coisa é e
mesmo nunca mais abraçado a renda das
pessoas
segundo o seu admirar muito alguém não
gostar muito de alguém contar essa
pessoa porque e refletir sobre isso e
três por acaso tinha vontade de abraçar
dela não abraçar mais conta para que
você fique à vontade pra finalmente mais
engraçado e a pergunta que eu fiz foi
porque quero fazer isso porque com quais
pessoas já tinham iniciado o estranho de
abraçar a marca dele e então refletir
porque as pessoas vão fazer duas coisas
a primeira é uma vontade incansável por
aprender ea segunda é uma vontade de
ensinar e aprender a lição e
constantemente nos últimos quase dez
anos trabalhando com a orientação do
empreendedorismo
essas duas coisas sanções acessórias ou
mais
e porque queria compartilhar com vocês é
que depois de ter a oportunidade de
trabalhar com de viverem de enganar
conselho de pessoas por dia
eleições a primeira coisa é compartilhar
com vocês um pouco da história da
humanidade e de como é que a gente pode
chegar a nossa história
os discípulos de aprendizado do ciclo de
sons
a segunda coisa é fazer uma sugestão de
um trem ea partir desse ciclo da
história da humanidade
a gente pode aceitar gente que a gente
já usa muito a gente faça hoje solas até
empresas ea terceira é tentar achar um
pouco de como que circula a primeira é
se conectar de alguma maneira podem
modificar a maneira como a gente
trabalha
então sei que aprender a comer essa
história queria falar um pouco pra vocês
ou morra jogos nove jogos é um cara que
eu admiro muito por quem não conhece o
ramo em homs é o fundador do grameen
bank banco de bangladesh darem crédito
para jovens de baixa renda
ele é o maior da paz 2006 e uma rampa e
coisa várias coisas internas com muita
atenção
ele falou assim todo ser humano nasce
empreendedor com alguns ganham a chance
de descartar essa capacidade
outros nunca tiveram a chance nunca
souberam que ele ou ela tem essa
capacidade
a história da humanidade lá atrás e
tentava pela nossa própria sobrevivência
a gente trabalhar ea gente tinha que
criar um software mais é mais um dos
fundadores da nossa própria ver a nossa
própria história
então o dn a criar o nosso sangue
então por que algumas pessoas achavam e
sobre os seis jogos só quem não conhece
os jogos a presidente durante muito
tempo e ele falou negócio mas temos 15
no rio dia
nós tentamos usar os nossos talentos
para expressar nossos sentimentos mais
profundos para mostrarmos apreciação
sobre todas as eleições passadas
deixaram para adicionar algo neste todos
realmente ninguém aqui com a gente
matinta junto à comida que a gente pode
pouco dela disse preta ea soma se a
gente junta militar ele foi criado e
tudo que a gente faz é deixar os nossos
aliados e os nossos filhos uma
contribuição para as gerações anteriores
se vier no meu avó quem gosta da boa
seus filhos e essa contribuição
normalmente fazem jejum
a gente olha a história da humanidade a
gente tá certo que todas as inovações
que foram surgindo então fazendo com
formações muito grandes
diante da nossa espécie assim mano elas
começaram muito pequenininhas aí já
estudar no fogo até a linguagem até o
papel que o primeiro computador nossos
celulares hoje fazem parte da nossa
filha a gente olhar pra história da
unidade desse ciclo de inovação
eles vêm ficando cada vez mais curtos ou
seja a dos agentes
aprendi a sony lançou a gente
a gente trabalha a mulher com judith e
quando a gente se aproxima desse ciclo
a gente olha cada degrau cada ponto em
uma grande descoberta e um ingresso na
sociedade
a gente passa por um grande momento
aprender e depois o senhor fernando
gonçalves que a gente tem o primeiro
momento tinha a imagem mais maluco conta
disso tudo é que nessas transformações
para acontecer isso agente do casal não
pode ter em seu carro sem vidro e vim
aqui hoje com isso perde em casa em jogo
nessas transformações de aprender e
sonhar reflexão que fica é se o ciclo só
revisão dos nossos sonhos dos círculos
atualizá-los também com reduzido impacto
na imagem se comporta o nosso dinheiro
não importa a sociedade vem
foi bem simples eu não sei o que passa
por um grande símbolo tinha nosso
vizinho e por vários livros ciclos já a
idéia de editar dois grandes sonhos
estilo regional já tem um desafio nesta
quinta que fica para cada um de vocês
você é amigo de vocês hoje e amanhã
qual é o seu sonho você acredita nesse
sonho sim o que você está fazendo para
chegar lá um sonho se você não acredita
mesmo a fazer nada chegar lá isso não só
é muito mais seguro quando o sonho nosso
a gente tá certo ele de qualquer linha e
quando você vê que a gente segue esse
ciclo existe um gatilho que faz a gente
lembrar o que acontece tem um tem em
conta o ponto tanta gente chama africano
para as vezes de território ea primeira
vitória é importante ajudar o seguinte
seria você tinha alguma coisa você
acredita em alguma coisa
você sabe fazer existe também muito
árduo e muito duro
edson nesta tarde
esse também aqui praticamente você sobe
a montanha evitar você tem que o novo
governo também algumas pessoas
desistiram até a vitória é importante
porque você tem que lembrar que às vezes
se submeteu às vezes maior
às vezes estou mais perto do sonho de
santos três pontos só tenho que podem
gerar a gente
o mais legal de tudo é que a gente uma
molécula que a gente não tenha clareza
do próximo passo que a gente vai
comemorar
então olha só era racional olha os
paradigmas se mudado de lá pra cá dois
marcadores mas quanta gente se
atualizando
vem mudando de atitude e uma coisa da
gente diz paradinhas a imagem dissesse
instituição estuda as velhas as novas
ações no mundo passa um pouco à nossa
frente é agente de passagem - celulares
pessoas por cidade
então tem de futuro
o nosso tem enfeitadas o me dedicar a
vitória a pf ele é aprender a aprender a
aprender a gente não possa também a
gente não tem mais vontade de aprender
a gente acaba desistindo no meio do
caminho existe uma psicologia da
aprendizagem professores inclusive
legais e ela fala assim a paixão por
aprender a não aprovação da sociedade
tem no sul é de 130 ela faz os jornais
ela tem uma roupa províncias para esse
grupo de finanças ela propõe um desafio
resolver o desafio e argentina por
exemplo precisa na hora seguinte ela
propôs mesmo desafio dar o melhor
ela propôs um novo desafio um pouco mais
livre para escolher um grupo de peças
escolheu o desafio anterior
um outro grupo de crianças orientadas a
ir a um novo desafio que fica por trás a
definir
decidiu se aventurar em um desafio que
ela já conhecia o outro grupo de
crianças decidir seguir mais um desafio
da onu e existe uma coisa muito
interessante que a gente vê todo dia um
agente sala de aula como professor faz
uma pergunta
as pessoas têm coragem de encarar não
são as pessoas que querem prova assim na
maioria dos casos a certeza da resposta
as pessoas se acham que é sorte não
tenha certeza delas
normalmente não têm a coragem de se
aventurar
mas o que a gente queria fazer nesse
horário porque quando a gente erra a
gente convida a gente vai ter de tudo
isso é que a gente não vencia a gente
chamasse debaixo de muita gente tem essa
consciência
a gente tem um coração das seis filhos a
cargo do ar
ele é muito interessante porque ele faz
a gente já teve
a aprovação da sociedade
bom quando a gente volta pra esse vem a
gente pode continuar sentindo nesta
semana sua imaginação disse a gente pode
chegar aqui a gente é esse
em 2010 até aqui
nossa imagina sambista que pode chegar
aqui a gente foi este último que dá
corpo a diferença
enquanto você segue o ciclo disse nada a
gente vai fazer
enquanto você percebe a distância do
sonhar da pequena vitória de maneira
pensada pois uma mulher
então é um crescimento contínuo e assim
vai
é uma coisa bacana
uma coisa é o seguinte o sucesso eo
fracasso nesse quando você não tem
definições segundo momento que a gente
percebe que o que era sucesso ou
fracasso tarde de hoje não pode ser
amigo pode mudar
a gente sabe que o santos empatasse com
a gente agora ele não tem o mesmo valor
em um estresse a gente porque alguém vai
mudar
já pararam para pensar quando você está
no trabalho seguinte mensagem você tem
uma filha num site só para mais com quem
se trabalha com a sua filha ea
mentalidade das pessoas vai mudando o
contato não gosta de ir pra caçar
depois do sucesso passageiro encontrar o
tom da mensagem que fica na saída toda
não é deixar de ter sido muita gente
gosta não gostar de poesia porque a
gente apaixonada
a nossa vida é muito curta a gente
encontrou um papel lá ea gente começa
agora iniciar no engenhão saiu
imagine a história da raça nas coisas
mudam
a gente se adapta a gente vai acabar
muito atrás a gente serve porque a gente
acredita que a gente já paguei paz e
lembrou que as novas uhs os ciclos
reduziram o tempo passou
então me sonhar sonhar que aprender a
ensinar e aprender
somos dois grandes pilares é importante
pra gente nesse símbolo do nosso
crescimento
sonhar acreditar fazer você vai
produzindo melhor um sonho novo ou você
vai se deslocar ou você decidir se
chegar mais perto de soltar o sonho de
um sonho sonho o sonho maior
então a gente olha a história da sua
mulher
o google gastou esse destino idealizado
a gente pensa que a gente fale chen se
eu podia continuar um pouco
a pergunta que eu quero deixar para todo
mundo aqui é dado que foi naquele tempo
que eu tinha sobre os seus sonhos sobre
a sua senha que você quer aprender com
isso também é comum é sobre território
nome nunca excesso de defender os seus
sonhos
você quer ninguém do século citando
vários a moção do pt no processo porque
eu sei fazer para chegar lá é lugar